now how many people's DMS are you
sliding into on on The Daily not very
often but I did you know this in
particular one changed my life because
you know this is what led to us becoming
co-owners co-chairman of the wrexham uh
Associated football club
um I I remember after we you know you'd
reached out about this absolutely insane
idea
and I remember uh coming showing up
seeing Blake and saying you know I have
I have bad news and I have really bad
news the bad news is I slipped into
someone's DMS again
um the really bad news is that you know
I might have bought half of a fifth year
national uh football league in Wales
what was their reaction uh not good Rob
no no not not great no yeah no yeah
we're still working through that one